[Music]
girls are just as good as boys in
anything we know how to hit we know how
to run and we can definitely play
football so when I heard boys chanting
beat that girl hate that girl Oh made me
want to do was beat them even better
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Sam Gordon I'm 14 years old and I
started the first female tackle football
league I've been playing with the boys
since I was nine years old in my very
first season I scored 35 touchdowns not
like 1,900 yards sometimes after I'd
beat him the parents would come out onto
the field to grab their sons case yes
and be like don't let a girl beat you I
wanted to start the girls tackle
football league after talking at a
school assembly and asking the question
how many girls here would want to play
tackle football almost every hand in the
room went up so I got the idea like okay
if there's this many at this one school
imagine how many there are in Utah or
just in the nation so I talked to my dad
and we talked with some other people
after a while we had the first season of
the Utah girls tackle Football League up
and running
football is the last frontier in girls
sports and if you think about it
girls can play on girls teams in every
sport that you can think of except for
the country's most popular sport we
limited participation to 50 girls those
spots filled up in less than a week the
following year we had 100 girls and then
this season we've had over 200 girls who
are playing every year we keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger it would be
amazing for it to go into high schools
colleges and even its own professional
league and that's gonna be a tough goal
to reach about I am really ambitious and
I feel like we could do it with the
girls you could tell that everybody
really wants to be there and so
everybody it's just super into it and
always willing to learn or with the
girls
every practice is just an awesome time
[Music]
you
normally there's this awkwardness around
disability but with that costume on
there that changed how people saw my son
they saw him first before they saw his
disability
it just helps break down that barrier
magic wheelchair is a nonprofit that
builds epic costumes for amazing kiddos
and wheelchairs magic wheelchairs
started when my son was 3 years old
Halloween rolled around and he wanted to
be a pirate we're new to the whole
disabilities and wheelchair thing we
didn't know anything about spinal
muscular atrophy I saw him sitting in
his wheelchair how we could dress them
up as a pirate be a pirate in a
wheelchair and let's let's build a ship
we have made probably about 40 different
costumes we have teams right now all
over the country we have a team in
France and working on a team in
Australia we're just gonna keep on
boarding teams because we want to build
year-round it's harder to build for
people that are in wheelchairs but it
ultimately starts with the kid it's
whatever they want to be and then we
make it a reality
[Music]
Halloween was kind of our initial push
but we're seeing like Comicon right
[Music]
and what's cool about that community of
cosplay that's a very supportive
community the the cold reality of
childhood diseases are some of them
won't be around for next Halloween
so let's find something that we can do
while they're here with us so they have
these that they have these great
memories and that they're their families
have memories when they're gone
[Music]
it's almost like a cure for the day
because they don't see the wheelchair
they just see these amazing kids and it
bridges gaps and overcomes that
awkwardness that we have in society I
mean their star the show oh it's awesome
to see
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's fun making passwords I mean
I don't like to do it from 9 a.m. to 10
o'clock at night but that's what it
comes with having a business you need to
do the order to don't just get money for
doing nothing
my name is Mira Modi and I love fast for
making as you know I make passwords that
are very secure and I have a website
where I sell them for a few dollars each
and I send them by postal mail
I roll dice to make strings of numbers
use the string of numbers to get
corresponding words in the destro
dictionary
I roll dice five times for each word oh
you do that six times for one password
so well the last 30 times and it
produces random words that have a lot of
entropy which means it's not easy for
the computer to hack kinds of like turn
into a thing I would do like if my mom's
friend you're like come over I'm like
hey can you make me a couple passwords
and I do it then I was like oh it's
making it to a website and here I mean
the website is kicking off and I'm
really excited about that
some people like say it being popular in
schools like the best thing ever I think
like this is so much better people
actually like learn from this and that's
good
[Music]
right after school and just like China
like one to the gym so I can climb it
it's a dangerous sport but I only think
that I'm afraid of is not being it looks
against there's others
[Music]
it's climbing I don't think that it
really matters it's how big you are
if you're smaller you can hold on longer
and your hands like these small ways so
it can fit my finger it's on hold I
started climbing in Central Park when I
was six years old
now I don't think I can like live
without it
[Music]
when you're close to the top of the
climb you're trying to do your funds
usually feel like they're gonna explode
and they're gonna like first open and
you feel like you have to let go but
with climbing you just can't let go I
think that climbing is it's obviously a
sport it's also like a dance you sort of
have to be able to like flow up the wall
and come up with your own techniques to
get to this complex
I think people shocked if I do something
that they can't do something because I'm
still really young and I'm a girl so
like doing something that even if a guy
can't do is pretty special
[Music]
and if you need I probably have if I
don't have it I can get it in 24 hours
fear up and you have a video shoot you
neither shoes coming out in two weeks
I just have to make a call and I'll get
it for you
[Music]
every day millions of people tuned to DJ
Khaled snapchat the key to more success
one of my favorite DJ kala pearance is
is this kid Ben how's business in a new
year oh I see you he's 16 years old and
he's at the helm of a burgeoning sneaker
empire when he says has done nearly a
million dollars in business and boasts
clients like DJ Cod and Chris Brown meet
this sneaker Don somebody is benjamin
capitalistic people call me Benjamin
cakes but most you guys know me as a
sneaker don school ends up three o'clock
I get home outlook for you dinner do
some homework and go straight to the
office space and like any good Don
family's important I'm his manager so if
you need anything call me okay not that
family I'm the mother of the sneaker Don
to me he's my little boy but I also see
a business then he had a goal he self
driven he's motivated he's a hard worker
the great Don's they say come from
humble beginnings the first pair of
sneakers actually got me a game I was in
fifth grade
the Galaxy pack came out and I got the
LeBrons I love sneakers after that
probably around sixth grade when my
parents didn't want to fund my sneaker
hobby anymore I just figure out a way
how to get the money for it and then I
realized if I buy five or ten pairs by
paying people to stand in line for me I
could sell it to a larger clientele and
make more money plus get my shoe for
free and then it just finally broke
through and money you started coming in
now first it amazed me how sneakers can
go for like so much money for like one
shoe people were charging a thousand I
thought it was a good joke or something
I was in dollars but hey that's why he's
the sneaker Don
so what comes next really excited to
open up a physical store the first of
all case doesn't mean Miami and then I'm
trying to do LA New York and Chicago all
my friends when they dropped out of
sneak game that like it's dead it's over
there's no more like you're not getting
on their thing you're wasting your time
they're gonna lose money he's not
available was true play themselves
indeed they did sneaker Don indeed they
did
[Music]
you